gallop did their end of the year
worldwide survey of 65 countries 64,000
people to find out if people were happy
with their lives and we've got some
findings Fiji is the happiest country in
the world 93% of people in Fiji said
they were happy while Iraq is the least
happy I guess that's no surprise there
only thirty-one percent Iraqis are happy
seventy percent of people worldwide say
they are happy with their life up from
sixty percent last year i think that's
fascinating Wow forty-two percent
believe that next year will be one of
economic prosperity for their country
and just twelve percent of Western
Europeans believe that 2015 will be a
year of economic prosperity so let's
start with the end of that there so it's
forty two percent thinking that economic
prosperity is coming to them seems
pretty wide eyed to me and yet Western
Europeans so we're talking about France
and England Spain they don't think that
what's going on there I don't know I
mean it's safe so all over the map all
this other statistics it just depends on
how people felt when you ask them that
right i mean i'd like to see to take all
three christmas bonus that day you're
feeling a little better yeah yeah but uh
one of economic prosperity I just feel
like there's probably in I don't know in
in Western Europe things have been
pretty shitty lately and so I think
they're just thinking it'll go through
and then I don't know i'd like to see
like a map of the world to see where
people are the happiest i liked it like
an island nation right of course fiji we
get it 93 procedure of fiji like how are
you not happy if you're a beautiful no
they're pretty good i think i've never
been to feed you my traditional water
yeah even we're back in the water those
bottles this is where bottle it's very
nice it's very alike score about could
we just go back to image one more time
for a quick second so the other part
that i thought was interesting is that
seventy percent say they're happy with
their life which is up from sixty
percent last year so that means you know
we hear this all the time that
everything's so shitty and we've talked
about a bunch on the show lately how it
seems like everything's awful because
we're so connected so we can all see the
horrible things that are happening ever
all the time but actually maybe things
aren't that terrible yeah seventy
percent it's good to see that seventy
percent of the people are like
he despite all the [ __ ] I've seen yeah
it's gonna be okay yeah that's good I
wonder if that I mean that seems like
you can round that's that's that's
encouraging that that might be like the
default human setting yeah it's like
that'll be better next time yes step to
actual prosperity i think is having a
good attitude and you know pushing for
more but at the same time we also at
least you know maybe in the u.s. we have
this feeling that you know don't get
content with anything keep pushing for
more do you better get more get get the
next thing but do you think we have a
little bit of that western european
thing going on the united states there
definitely is a sense here i think that
our best days are kind of behind us
which is also almost like a
self-fulfilling prophecy in a way like
if you start thinking it yeah i don't
think it's actually the case things but
I think we stash it back in the day yeah
i mean it is getting a little bit better
at least socially yeah i think a lot of
people would probably argue with that
but i think that probably that's
probably and he still have huge problems
clearly it's better than slave days you
know it's better than that and you know
and obama says that too he's like it's
better it's not perfect but like come on
yeah I I did think that was interesting
when Obama said this week about how race
relations are better now and then he was
getting such [ __ ] for it and it's like I
get it there is bad stuff going on but
it's way better than it was 20 so much
it just is and that doesn't mean the
police are doing the right thing I get
just all of it oh yeah we're no one's
resting on their laurels here but like
let's put things in perspective there's
are those things where like what kind of
teacher do you want do you want the
teacher who's like no it's terrible all
the time life sucks and we got to get
better or the one who's like okay yes
there's here the areas we can improve on
but like I also want you to know that
you're making progress yeah and I know
it doesn't feel that way for everybody
and that's fine but like you know we
were still improving and what it shows
how much more we can improve is the fact
that we've improved so let's acknowledge
that right because if you don't
acknowledge it then it's hard to move
forward I think we we do get lost that
final thought of this what is your
definition of happy Kim [ __ ] sure uh
being personally fulfilled in
my career I think that's it career
you're good to go I I feel like there
might be part of me broken cuz I don't
really got running a boyfriend or
husband at this point I don't give a
[ __ ] let's make this career happen Wow
all right haha Brett me I'm man
spreading right now so look at this guy
i honest I got to the point where it was
so uncomfortable I had to man's friend
he is if you don't know what man
spreading is we just did a segment on it
annotation right there he's sitting with
his legs wide open what makes me happy
it's if you comment and like right down
below